a bunch of ex Google employees have come
out with a website called Buddha Go
which is a new search engine there you
go it is just for porn and the reason
that they did this was because they
found that it's very hard to go to
Google or go to Yahoo or who else do you
like for the search you like that is she
being like DuckDuckGo that's a that's I
just heard about that one so that one
kind of cleans up a lot of the internet
mess and that's what this Buddha NGO is
going to do for porn because if you were
to search for say [ __ ] not that I've
ever done this on the computer there
this is the type of thing that you get
now if you're looking for [ __ ] you
probably want to see a [ __ ] right
that's how it works but you get a lot of
informational stuff the Wikipedia
definition of [ __ ] you're not getting
porn and they wanted to quote find
legitimate legal non-scary nondamaging
content for their adult entertainment
needs and I don't if you guys know this
but there is porn on the the computer
networks there and a lot of people are
watching and people are afraid to talk
about it so they wanted to sort of
legitimize it let's look at a tumblr
search for porn because there's a lot of
porn on tumblr yeah there's not much on
tumblr even though tumblers filled with
porn they're kind of filtering it now
let's look at the same search for porn
on Buddha go and then there you go okay
you're gonna get some porn so they're
they're kind of doing what everything
else is doing they're curating right
this is all the things that we use all
the time they're curating Dylan horn
curation first of all let me say you
sent me this link for research thank you
and then I didn't get much done after
that I think it is a beautiful thing
that somebody is curating porn I think
it is about time that we started
pretending porn was as valuable as
museum artifacts I think it's another
porn site and it's a way of getting to
points not it's nice that it doesn't
keep track of all the way there no
cookies I you know one time
you'd do a fetish search on Google and
then for the rest of your life it
guesses that's what you're starting to
type again yeah that can that can get
exhausting the ad when you're looking on
Raw Story yeah but sling spinning Asian
but sling yeah the cookies are annoying
I think Buddha go gets you around some
of that but I am not all that excited
that there's a new way to search for
poor not having trouble finding before
another place to go to do the same three
painfully specific embarrassingly lame
fetish searches that I do at the places
that I've been doing them since the
advent of AOL I hear yeah but I think
the reason I like the story was because
there's something about a bunch of ex
Google people kind of normalizing it you
know anyway and it's like there's still
this stigma to porn mainstream companies
don't want to do it all the videos
online are porn and yet people don't
want to advertise on porn so there was
something about it that I thought was
like we're actually bringing we're kind
of getting it out in the open that I
thought was kind of healthy or something
about it Google guys know we're a source
of money is yeah and then they went gee
what are we missing on the Internet
that's a huge source of money yeah
wait a second fellas what you have to
wait for is when Marlboro gets to hold
the pornography because they're gonna
add in all the addictive additive and
that they put the dick back in addicted
we should probably get into the what
what if we did this show naked do you
think it would help the numbers I'm
animus which no a lot of layers on that
would be a sign well yeah that's because
I borrow a pen Gillette suit for this
show
[Music]